Do you think if you
just stood on it?
and we turned it up to
full pressure
and you just open
would you just jet off?
Yeah.
Yes!
Oh!
( laughs )
It's so slippy.
Not a bad start.
How many-- ( laughs )
- Before I fall, adjustment.
- No.
That was pro-bo.
- Ooh.
- Oh.
Gav: Hey, look at that!
Whoa, ( bleep )!
( laughter )
Gav: Can we cut?
( laughs )
You blasted him.
You hit him right
in the face.
Hey, he just took
it to the face there.
Couldn't be more perfect.
( laughter )
Dan: If you saw that
coming towards you in battle.
- ( laughter )
- Gav: I'd probably laugh
at you.
Oh, you're going towards
the steps.
Dan: Oh, God, I'm gonna fall
over the steps here.
- Gav: ( laughter )
Had to bail.
- Dan: I had to do it.
Almost went over the steps.
Why don't we end
with a classic
we've modified,
our firehose.
Now it has a giant balloon
on the end of it.
I mean, usually we fill
these up with a garden hose.
20 minutes, probably.
I reckon this'll do it
within two minutes.
- Two minutes.
- Yeah.
Your hose is inside it.
- ( water splashing )
- Oh, Jesus!
( laughter )
- ( balloon popping )
- ( water splashing )
Gav: I think you'll see me
freak out.
I'm like, "Better get out
of the water."
I don't know
why jumping would help,
because where am I
going to land?
Dan: Look at you.
( laughter )
Gav: I thought that
was good reactions.
It's like a tsunami
to a giant.
Is that-- no.
Does that make sense?
- I'm not sure.
- No, it doesn't.
- Hello there, internet.
Gav here.
- And Dan.
If you didn't already,
please subscribe to
The Slow Mo Guys,
right now for our
latest videos.
Yes, stay connected
with us
so we can stay
connected with you.
- Creepy.
- Sorry.
- A bit creepy.